hier le président zelensky s'est rendu
sur place il évoqué un génocide deux
jours après ces découvertes macabres eh
bien la france annonce l'ouverture de 3
nouvelles enquête pour crimes de guerre
c'est le parquet antiterroriste français
qui l'annoncent karim hakiki bonjour
pourquoi cette intervention de la
justice française
sont l'application des dispositions
légales les compétences des juridictions
françaises comme le pmad peuvent être
retenue en cas de crimes de guerre
commis hors du territoire national parce
qu'il s'agit là de l'ukraine mais qui
concernent des français les faits sont
précis ces trois nouvelles enquêtes
concernent d'abord ce qui s'est passé à
mario paul entre le 25 février et le 16
mars agosto mails entre le 1er et le 12
mars ils ont fait un tir vif le 24
février la le pénates et n'a pas
compétence pour enquêter sur toute la
période de la guerre il est saisi pour
certaines compétences d'ailleurs pour
bocsa il est possible que dans quelques
jours on puisse avoir une nouvelle
saisine du parquet national anti
terroriste qu'est ce que la france à
cette juridiction universelle qui lui
permet est d'instruire cette affaire
d'ailleurs les crimes de guerre ont déjà
été retenus et jugé en france notamment
des génocides on se souvient du génocide
rwandais qui a été jugé en france à
plusieurs reprises et le pn à terre a
confié les investigations à l'office
central de lutte contre les crimes de
guerre les crimes de haine cet office a
l'habitude d'enquêté donc ça va être une
enquête au long cours difficile d'abord
pour établir les faits retrouvez les
responsabilités des uns et des autres
même si certains sont déjà pointés du
doigt et notamment pour du côté de
moscou mais il va falloir trouver les
officiers qui étaient en charge c'est
tout c'est tout l'intérêt de cette
enquête et puis avant une première
enquête avait déjà été ouverte cette
fois mi mars après la mort du
journaliste franco et hollandais piet
rakowski donc c'est la quatrième enquête
qui est couverte ouverte par le parquet
national anti terroriste ce sont des
enquêtes au long cours
très probablement qu'ils seront jugés
d'ici trois quatre ou cinq ans justement
pour établir cette commission rogatoire
parce que les enquêteurs français
devront se déplacer sur place pour aider
sans identifier les victimes et savoir
qui a fait quoi à ce moment là donc on
n'aura pas un procès avant cinq ans mais
la procédure est engagée à partir du
moment où elle est engagée on peut pas
revenir en arrière merci pour ces
précisions karim